québec va élargir le système de consigne
à toutes les bouteilles et canettes les
contenants de cartons seront inclus dans
un deuxième temps les québécois
consomment pas moins de 250 millions de
bouteilles de vins et spiritueux par
année c'est 3 milliards 750 millions de
contenants de verre de plastique de
métal qui feront l'objet d'une consigne
à 10 cents
ce sera 25 cents pour les bouteilles de
vin avec 10% des contenants non
retournés à terme ça veut donc dire 44
millions de dollars qui sont investis
pour les centres de tri la collecte et
les coûts du système on vous propose
l'analyse de patrick gonzales ce soir
qui est professeur au département
d'économie à l'université laval à québec
pour soi monsieur gonzalez un bon sens
opinion vous aviez été mandaté en 2015
par le gouvernement de l'époque pour
évaluer justement des scénarios de
consignation est ce que québec
aujourd'hui nous présente un bon
programme de consignes on serait
beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire parce que
ça met en cause comment va fonctionner
la collecte sélective par la suite qui
va financer quoi est ce on n'en sait
rien pour l'instant pas plus con c'est
aussi sous quelle forme va prendre s'ils
vont prendre ces centres de récupération
est ce que ça va être des gobelins
moderne installés dans des endroits
facilement accessible pour les
consommateurs ou d'obscurs sans le dépôt
au fond des parcs industriels pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien on parle de
projets pilotes donc va falloir attendre
pour de voir la suite le ministre nous a
annoncé que avoir plus de développement
du côté des
de la collecte sélective et c'est à ce
moment là on pourra voir son ensemble du
système
si c'est un bon plan ou non et donc on
sait pas trop ce qui va avec les centres
de tri donc lui non mais j'ai
l'impression lecture de ce qui était
annoncé aujourd'hui c'est que on s'est
donné les moyens pour intervenir au
centre auprès des centres de tri les
moyens financiers entre quoi nous et
moins alors parlons ddd des consignes
justement 25 cents pour une bouteille de
vin est ce que c'est le bon prix soit
pour changer les comportements 25
semaines c'est certainement assez pour
changer les comportements
mais changer les comportements dans ce
cas-ci ce que ça va vouloir dire c'est
sortir la bouteille de vin du bac bleu
il y avait déjà un bon taux de
récupération avec la bouteille de vin
dans le bac bleu mais ça nuisait y avait
beaucoup de plaintes
du côté des centres de tri ou du côté
des acheteurs de ballots que ça crée de
la contamination
je crois que c'était un des objectifs de
cet effort du gouvernement c'est de
régler ce problème là donc de sortir la
bouteille de vin du black blue
exactement sacs de recyclage exactement
et à 25 cents vous pensez qu'avec la
consigne là ça va être un bon
encouragement pour le faire c'est
certainement on envoie le message pour
le faire clairement les gens
volontairement mettaient leurs
bouteilles comme on leur demandait de
faire d'ailleurs un c'était c'était ce
qui était prévu dans le système mais je
pense que signal est assez clair qu'on
veut que la bouteille de vin n'est plus
dans le bac bleu pour les autres
contenus on parle de 5 ou 10 cents
est-ce que c'est efficace s'avère
efficace pour une partie de la
population une partie de la population
qui réagit bien qui est sensible à la
consigne mais c'est certainement pas
toute la population actuellement si vous
allez sur vous prenez des chiffres même
de recyc québec avec les consignes qui
existe depuis longtemps à ces montants
là on a des taux de récupération qui
dépasse pas 70 pour ça donc je crois moi
personnellement qu'on sous-évaluent
volant thermale grossièrement le
la quantité de contenus qui seront pas
retournés ou plutôt la quantité de
consigne qui ne seront pas remboursés
je pense que en imposant une consigne à
l'ensemble des contenus on va surtout
créer un beau pactole avec laquelle le
gouvernement va pouvoir éventuellement
aider les centres de tri ou revitalisée
par ailleurs la collecte sélective pour
remarquer qu'il faut tenir en compte que
si on sort de la matière du bac bleu ben
les entreprises qui paient actuellement
pour contrainte cette matière là sont
plus disposés à payer les mêmes montants
donc quand même falloir il va avoir une
perte je crois financière du côté des
bacs bleus qui va être en partie
compensée par ce coup les montants que
les consommateurs qui ne reporte pas le
contenant vont laisser donc quand vous
parlez de pactole est ce que vous voulez
vous laissez entendre dans le fond que
il ya une bonne partie de la consigne
qui sera pas que les gens ne
retourneront pas les contenants est ce
que c'est ce que j'ai compris c'est ce
que tout à fait oui je pense qu'on peut
parler d'un bon tiers probablement donc
est-ce qu'on atteint nos objectifs
environnementaux quand on fait ça parce
qu'il ya un objectif environnemental
avec tout ça il n'y a pas que oui mais
l'argent est important
l'argent est important parce que avoir
un système de recyclage efficace moderne
ça coûte cher puis vous quelqu'un paie
quelque part c'est toujours le
consommateur qui paie avec un système de
consigne
ça devient un peu volontaire en ce sens
que ceux qui souvent plus riches qui
décide que finalement ils ont d'autres
choses à faire que d'aller rapporter
leurs contenants b dans le fond ils
payent par le montant de la consigne
c'était
une taxe que peuvent éviter ceux qui
sont plus diligent puis qu'ils vont
aller rapporter leurs contenus dans les
centres de dépôt et il faut tenir compte
aussi qu'il ya d'importants frais de
traitement par la consigne est donc une
bonne partie des montagnes qui vont être
ramasse qui vont être cumulée comme ça
vont servir justement à payer le système
comme vous l'avez évoqué en début
d'entrevue
c'est à dire qu'il faut payer les gens
il faut payer les locaux où sont
accumulées ces contenants là les gens
qui les tris tout ça c'est pas gratuit
tout ça donc vous fondamentalement ce
que vous pensez que c'est un bon choix
de se tourner comme ça vers
l'élargissement de la consigne
personnellement je suis pas un grand fan
de la consigne lorsqu'on l'emploi pour
des produits jetables qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de valeur je crois que c'est un
outil très puissant pour motiver les
gens même si vous me demandez à moi
j'aime bien utiliser les ressources
humaines les motiver pour des choses qui
ont beaucoup de valeur
maintenant je pas offert de préjugés là
dessus des gens qui vont trouver que
c'est bien utile d'aller apporter leurs
contenants mais je suis pas très à
l'aise quand con quand ça a été évoquée
parfois je me souviens d'avoir lu par
exemple une chronique de mario dumont
que je trouvais que juste à propos qui
disait que les consuls et québécois ont
bien d'autres choses à faire que de
rapporter tout le temps leurs contenants
ouais c'est l avantage de la collecte
sélective c'est qu'on simplifier la vie
des gens c'est clair qu'avec la consigne
on mobilise davantage les gens pour
finalement faire fonctionner dustrit qui
est très bien qui est nécessaire qui
elle est utile dans l'environnement mais
bon il ya 24 heures dans une journée et
les commerçants aussi les restaurateurs
se posent à la consigne énergie et en
général pour différentes raisons ils
peuvent s'y opposer pour des raisons
pécuniaires parce que quand il semble
que leur rôle et leur contribution
wojtek rue ça c'est une chose on va
falloir que tout le monde fasse sa part
quelque part qui va avoir des
négociations qui vont se faire à cet
effet là mais ils s'y opposent aussi
souvent lorsqu'on parle d'en faire des
centres de dépôt accessoires et là je
pense qu'ils ont un excellent
argumentaire je pense par exemple au sao
au supermarché c'est vraiment le dernier
endroit où on veut rapporter des
contenances alors à ce moment il faut
distinguer la à quel point ce se situe
leur opposition à ce moment là patrick
gonzalèz merci pour cette analyse ce
soir ça m'a fait plaisir